[Music]  they're looking for you what are these  what if I told you there's a place where  people have powers like us city of  Adeline and I can take you there  we're in humans  [Music]  maybe I'm foolish maybe I'm blind  thinking I can see through this save us  behind  brother sooner or later the humans are  going to find us got no way to prove it  so maybe I'm not the first course of  action will be to try to destroy us one  I'm only human after all we need to go  to earth now we need to strike first it  would only lead to war  are you speaking for yourself or for our  King  [Music]  Maximus is trying to take over Adeline  are you going to kill your only brother  I'm only human after honor me as your  new king after all don't put the blame  on me  never don't put your blame on me you're  just a human  [Music]